nfl it never really is normal per se
there's always something going on and
the new normal for the seahawks and
russell wilson is some degree of
dysfunction i thought that
that they'd
maybe talked and
ironed things out and i poked around a
little bit on that late last week and it
turned out that just because we hadn't
heard anything didn't mean that anything
had been solved there are still issues
there it's a fluid relationship between
the seahawks and russell wilson there
are now reports that a third of the
league has called
the seahawks about the availability of
quarterback russell wilson and the
belief in league circles is that the
starting point is three first-round
picks now
i don't know whether to what extent the
seahawks are slamming the phone down
whether they are saying things that are
causing people to believe the starting
point is three first-round picks and
again that's just the starting point
that's the anti that's the price to get
you to the table you're gonna get
squeezed up off of that if you
ultimately get russell wilson
and hey three first round picks
it all depends upon where the first
round picks are there's a big difference
between pick one and pick 32 shireen but
i don't think three first-round pictures
as a starting point is all that
all that uh ridiculous the question is
where does it end up and the question is
are the seahawks ready to downgrade
financially the amount of money that
they're investing in the quarterback
position to get back to the days when
they had a younger guy it was when they
had a younger guy and a cheaper guy they
were in two super bowls
you know what the most surprising part
of this report is mike that only a third
of the league has called what's the
wrestling doing i mean come on make a
call
if they hang up on the phone on you they
hang up the phone on you if they say
we're not trading them they say we're
not training them but why wouldn't you
call why wouldn't you make an offer to
the seahawks it's the same thing with
houston perhaps they turn you down now
but they come back to you later i just
think you have to make the call and and
there are at least half the teams in the
league that should be calling both
houston and seattle to say hey what's it
going to take and frankly
three first-round picks i'm all in count
me in on that i'll give you the three
round picks and and let's go so if
you're the jets or somebody i'm i'm
absolutely making that call probably
even the jaguars making that phone call
uh to seattle just to see what it will
take it's crazy mike that that that's uh
all it would be and i think it will end
up being more if he is traded i do think
they work things out this year but i
think it possibly probably maybe is his
last year in seattle but mike silver in
that report made a really good point
mike and i hadn't thought about this but
the seattle situation in the houston
situation is exactly the opposite in
seattle it's russell wilson that's doing
all the talking and the seahawks have
been silent in houston it's the texans
doing all the talking and deshaun watson
has been silent and you wrote about that
saying maybe it's time for deshawn
watson to come out and say something
well
and and i think their circumstances are
very different russell wilson has given
it time after time and opportunity after
opportunity to become the kind of thing
that he thinks will help him achieve his
personal goals and ambitions of having
multiple championships he's now been
there nine seasons this is a guy who
went to the super bowl twice in his
first three years
2013-2014 hasn't been beyond the
divisional round since then and i think
it's gotten exasperated in the way they
run the offense the way they run the
team and he's ready to try it a
different way simply so that when he
gets to the end of his career he will
have more pelts on the wall than he
currently does he's got to be having a
football midlife crisis that is causing
him to say my legacy
should be
stronger at this point after nine
seasons desean watson's just getting
starting and i started realizing that
he's he's caught in a in a
mess of dysfunction that is going to
prevent him from even getting to a super
bowl so he's got a different priority
and a different objective altogether but
same thing quarterbacks in this age of
tom brady showing them how it's done
realizing that they have power and
they're going to use it and they're
going to use it in different ways
and
you know you touched on something with
the possibility the jaguars or the jets
they have picks that are high enough
that that one first round pick becomes a
lot more enticing if you're the jaguars
and you're offering the number one
overall pick and think back to 2018 when
reportedly and this is something that
chris sims started a year or two ago and
others have glommed onto it the seahawks
talking to browns about the possibility
of wilson to cleveland three years ago
for the number one overall pick the
belief josh allen would have been the
selection of the seattle seahawks so
if there there are some similarities
between trevor lawrence and josh allen
and
maybe that would attract the seahawks if
the jaguars want to do it the other wild
card in that though would russell wilson
want to go
to jacksonville if it came down to
jacksonville versus new york
jacksonville versus new york when you
consider his lifestyle when you consider
his spouse
ciara new york is going to be preferred
to jacksonville and that's relevant
because russell wilson has a no trade
clause but again
early first round picks
far more attractive than later first
round picks and if the patriots show up
and offer three first rounder a three
first rounders that that's far different
than the jets of the jaguars who can
give
a high first rounder right now at a time
when the seahawks could then take that
pick and turn it into a quarterback who
would be under a weight scale rookie
deal for for five years with much less
paid over those five years than what
russell wilson is currently getting
yeah and and mike again i i do think
they work this out for at least one year
i think he's back for one year but it's
all stems from the frustration as you
pointed out of getting to super bowls
two of his first three seasons i mean
they haven't won it since 2013 haven't
been there since 2014 and they're three
and five since then in the postseason
and and the one and done this year
really stands out and i know there's a
bunch of frustration from that because
you know mid-season we're talking about
this team being the best in the nfl
we're talking about russell wilson being
an mvp candidate not only an mvp
candidate but the leading candidate at
mid-season and it all went south those
last eight games last half of the season
somewhere in there and then the one and
done in the postseason so a lot of
frustration right now from russell
wilson and i'm sure from the seahawks
organization too with the way the season
went they didn't expect it to end like
it did it did it ended far too soon in
their minds should not have lost the
rams in the first playoff game and now
here they sit trying to figure out how
to make this a better team going forward
and russell wilson's got to be a part of
that mike to give you a chance to go do
what you think you have the team to do
now they they do need some upgrades
especially on defense and in the
offensive line as he's pointed out but
they have the core right there mike to
go back to the super bowl to be one of
the contenders in the nfc
one of the other things to keep in mind
a trade that would be accomplished
before june 1 would result in 39 million
in dead cap money hitting seattle's
salary cap this year a trade would have
to be post june 2nd and i think the way
to do it especially because now we see
so many deals that are done before
they're officially done you work out the
deal now or whenever between now and
june 2nd everyone knows the paperwork
goes through on june 2nd and until then
russell wilson gets together with his
new teammates receivers running backs
tight ends and they work on their own
which
which may be the only thing that we
would see this year anyway because of
the pandemic and the likelihood of a
limited off-season program so waiting
until june 2 and any other year would
have been inconceivable for a
quarterback trade because you want the
guy in the door
asafp
now
with the pandemic and given this this
shift away from intense offseason
workout programs if you gotta wait until
june two you gotta wait until june two
and and look if that's part of the price
of admission you got to show up with
three first round picks and you got to
wait until june two teams are going to
show up with three first round picks and
an engraved statement that yes they will
wait until june 2 to get the deal done
and they won't renege on the deal
because that would be a major problem
for everyone involved as well it would
be a problem for the team doing the deal
to get russell wilson because other
opportunities would go out the window
between whenever and june 2. so i'm not
ready to rule it out completely i think
that
at some point shireen this reaches
critical mass where it becomes spoken
into existence
and if more teams keep calling and if
the seahawks engage at all and they
start to realize you know what we may be
better off long term we're just a couple
of years away from another renegotiation
and mark rogers russell wilson's agent
is going to want market value money do
we really want to give 45 million plus
to russell wilson do we really want to
do another year extension do we really
want to deal again with this guy who has
one football client who can drive the
hardest possible bargain with us without
worrying about how it may affect any of
his other clients that's one of the
benefits of having a one client agent
that may be something the seahawks are
happy to move on from so
the more that gets put on the table in
front of them
i think the more likely they just decide
to be done with it now and the other
reality of this too is who's calling the
shots here someone suggested me last
week that
that
the seahawks are one of the closest
things we have other than the packers to
corporate ownership that it's vulcan
that's really running that show and pete
carroll's got a lot of authority but
it's not really jody allen paul allen's
sister acting like a normal owner so
that that makes it complicated from the
standpoint of who ultimately flips the
switch from no to yes who's got that
authority who's got that power it's kind
of confusing right now in seattle as to
who the one person is that can say yeah
we're going to do this and we're going
to take the maximum offer we can and
we're going to start this process of
trying to come up with the best possible
offer three first rounders plus whatever
so we still don't know who that person
is in a normal team you know who it is
it's the owner with this team we don't
know and that's just another dynamic
that makes this even more fascinating
yeah and mike if i'm the jets or the
dolphins or the jaguars those teams we
talked about that have have those high
picks i'm definitely making that call to
see
what it would take are they listening
hey if you start listing where on this
but i would make an offer i would try to
make an offer they can't refuse i just
think you take the sure thing over
even a trevor lawrence who looks like
the best quarterback prospect probably
since andrew luck but we don't know we
haven't seen a ton of these number one
overall picks come out and do what we
expected them to do so why not take the
guy who already is the franchise
quarterback who is headed toward the
hall of fame
instead of taking a risk and rolling the
dice on a guy in the draft or whatever
there's just so many teams right now
that are looking for quarterbacks i just
think you have to make calls to both
teams to see what it takes and yes it's
going to hurt it's going to hurt for a
long time you have to figure out how you
can build a team with probably not a lot
of first-round draft picks kind of what
the rams have done frankly over the
years in building their team is not
having those first-round draft picks and
not having a lot of draft picks to build
the team around you're going to have to
draft really well on the lower rounds so
you have to figure out how to put a a
team around him but if you need a
franchise quarterback and we know more
than half the teams in this league do
they're looking to upgrade even teams
like san francisco with jimmy garoppolo
i just think you make that call mike
but see that's the philosophical
question what does a team value more the
sure thing
are all the other lottery tickets you
can trade for the sure thing and and the
question becomes
if someone makes an offer to the
seahawks whatever it is whatever the
offer is that they can't refuse
and then they look at it and they say
well wait a minute if that team is
willing to give us all that stuff for
russell wilson maybe we got something
here like why do they want him that
badly why are they willing to give up
all this stuff maybe we should just keep
him and then the offer that they can't
refuse has to go even higher and it all
comes down to how you value
the sure thing how you value the guy
who's been in the league for nine years
and proven he can do it versus how you
value your ability to take those picks
and turn them into
mini jackpots that collectively are
worth more or at least as much as that
sure thing so
again it comes down to how you approach
these things philosophically you need
a team that is willing to give up a lot
of stuff from a draft capital standpoint
for the sure thing and you need a team
that is willing to trade in the sure
thing with the confidence slash hubris
that they can take those draft picks and
completely revitalize the team it's not
it's not going to be easy to do it's not
going to be easy to do and in some
respects it may be harder to pull it off
with the seahawks than with the texans
because it's not like russell wilson is
going to refuse to show up if he doesn't
get traded
and it's easier for the seahawks to say
no we'll give it one more year we'll
continue to keep russell wilson on the
roster for one more season and see if
through the process of 2021 with shane
waldron as the offensive coordinator
maybe we can find a way to make this guy
want to renew his vows and stay with the
seahawks indefinitely but at this point
feels like an uphill climb for the
seattle seahawks to make russell wilson
happy assuming they try to do so in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports